so no hero is a 2d cover base
shoot-'em-up if you're over the age of
30 is like blackthorn meets elevator
action and if you're under the age of 30
it's like Gears of War meets something
else gunpoint let's go with gunpoint so
it's all about sliding taking cover
hiding and keeping an eye on your ammo
if you don't give in i only remember you
gotta die a lot like that so black arts
and menacing guy called Steve there's a
whole bunch of different labels he's
like the first guy you get he's just got
a pistol and all the basic moves he can
just slide and shoot that's an hour of
power of those little boxes give you
different types of bullets these ones
are explosive
so I each mission has different
objectives some of them are ridiculous
some of them a sensible this one you
just have to kill everyone and we
escaped that's funny lord in the
helicopter is a purple time-traveling
rabbit from the future he's come back to
try and win the mayoral elections in
town and he's going to do that by
murdering every other candidate so
there's like multiple ways are going
through the level you don't have to use
the staircases you can like jump out of
windows and jump back in again all right
so this is like a drill bone basically
when you fire it's going to go to rock
drill through the floor and explode so
if you jump out of this window and try
and come into this floor instead of that
floor now hit see that kind of worked I
know it totally worked let's go in hey
Zeus
so this is like each character in the
game has pretty much the same move
served with a couple of tweaks so Jesus
can't slide tackle people but he can
slide and shoot at the same time and his
guns a total bullet hose
like there are three different writings
you go down the level which is score
time and something else by the number of
times you got shot I'm so like the ideas
to replay each level with different
characters to try and like beat it in
different ways oh my jesus is really
good for speedrunning because he's super
fast whereas some of h steve is really
tired school like he's better foot
popper so he's better at doing and try
not to get here someone like Cletus is
working for combos you're in so much
trouble right now I'm quietly confident
you gonna do it this time
so you've got the best be basically
doubled the size of your clip and you've
doubled your rate of fire with this
power so you have a lot of bullets right
now
really
please use the cat one maybe not now but
soon so if you go all the way to the
right and jump down into that and then
unleash the cat of misery and death